at the border of Chad and Sudan in the
town of adre a humanitarian disaster is
unfolding says the United Nations half a
million Sudanese refugees are living in
makeshift tents hungry
tired and in shock images of the
violence they have left behind
circulating on social media show men
women and children buried alive in Mass
Graves signs of possible crimes against
humanity committed in the darur region
as the conflict in Sudan shows no sign
of
ending they attacked us for 3 days it
was intense they went from door to door
running up the men they took them out
and killed them they called the father
of my children into the street shut him
and kill him they took everything away
from us and I have nothing to take care
of my children we have no choice but to
flee to Chad more sudanes have fled to
Chad in the past 6 months than in the
past 20 years most are from the darur
region they walk for days without food
and water according to the UN 90% of the
new arrivals show signs of malnutrition
Aid agencies say they are overwhelmed
and underfunded the chadians they have
already shared whatever they could share
they can't share anymore they even need
assistance themselves so now we need to
assist all those 600 refugees that came
the retur from Chad that were living
there but also now we also need to
support the Chad and the host population
that are there that are also suffering
like all those Sudanese that have
arrived the world food program says it
has barely enough funding for the next 3
months and yet Chad is hosting more than
1 million refugees one of the largest
and fastest growing populations in
Africa almost a decade after the
violence in Dar for
once again the UN is warning of a
spiraling catastrophe the world cannot
ignore Nicholas Hawk Al
jazer make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer